episode 4 09 is similar to episode 20
and I in the Blackwater episode in that
it's contained to one location one night
that said it's much more involved in
Blackwater was after we saw how well
Blackwater had come out we thought it
would be great to get neil marshall back
when we eventually have the battle at
the wall the whole episode not the whole
episode i guess 15 minutes into it it
becomes a battle and it's easy to get a
little bit monotonous if it's just guys
charging at each other for 45 minutes
straight and so part of the challenge is
trying to find these little moments that
will stand out on their own and a big
challenge is just finding time to do
everything because there's so many
action beats that you want and action
beats are always the slowest to get
right or take the most time that was
time intensive and it was all night
shoots like Blackwater so there's
there's certainly some similarities
our vows never specifically forbid
intimate relations with women what I
shall take no wife yes that's in there's
no denying that I shall father no
children's very specific but what I
found have to say about other activities
he's open to interpretation Sam is a
very literary fellow and he's given a
lot of attention to the vows and he's
not quite sure that the vows me and what
everyone interprets them to me because
after all there's nothing specific in
the vows that says you can't lie with
the woman it just says you know you
can't father any children there's also
bit of hypocrisy to it because brothers
of the Nights Watch have been going to
the moles town brothel forever that's
why there is a moles town brothel from
sams point of view he's in love with his
girl Gilly and what's wrong with that as
long as he continues to maintain as well
as as they're literally stated then he's
not actually betraying the Nights Watch
John's not quite so sure that anyone
sees it that way and as he says I don't
think sarala she was really much for
interpretation it's just fun to see
those two guys together you know
whenever possible is kind of the quiet
before the storm scene and there are a
few of those scenes that we really love
I am a man of the Nights Watch giving I
made a promise to defend the wall and I
have to keep it because that's what men
do there is a sort of native sense of
honor to him not necessarily in the John
Snow heroic mode Sam is absolutely
petrified but he knows he has to do that
and as he says you know this is made
noth and this is what men do and he's
not going to betray his brothers by
staying down there and avoiding the
fight
held the gate this episode is a regular
slaughterhouse where yeah we're killing
off a few favorites gren goes out again
with great heroism that Tim and his
small party face off against a giant
although they lose they do kill the
giant as well so they do save the day
and protect the Gateway to Castle black
and south they do a very noble deed this
battle is one that we've been planning
for a long time and we have these actors
that we love Joseph Alton s Pip and Mark
Stanley as grand and one neither the
characters died in the books it felt
like we had to have some casualties
amongst the people that we really care
about here he decided it should be
granted because grant someone we've seen
from quite nearly the very beginning in
the series and he's always been around
he's quite loyal and steadfast we knew
that people would care about him you
know down there and it's a great scene
and we love seeing him really take
command and his in his final moments and
stir his comrades to to courage you know
we're setting the rouse and tunnel scene
worked out beautifully I pledged my life
I know thats in the Nights Watch
yes John as well as to go through some
major heartbreak but at the same time
he's stepping up to leadership when it's
needed when things aren't the worst
people are at the best and he certainly
steps obstacles you have the wall
obviously kids the center of this
episode he's the centerpiece of the
episode watching him assumed the mantle
of authority without particularly
wanting to assume the mantle of
authority there was one scene I remember
watching and we said rewind there's
somebody put over that weird speed up
you know like a speed ramp on kits sword
moved there it looks it looks fake it
looks too fast we fix whatever somebody
did to that shot and Chris the visual
effects editor looked at and he said
there's no speed ramp on the shot like
that's that's the speed at which he's
moving with this big heavy aluminum
sword it's very rare to find somebody
who was both has the acting chops that
kit has in the ability to say so much in
such a subtle way he's an action hero
when a gret sees Jon who she's talked
about killing many many times over the
course of the season she hesitates it
harks back to the first episode of the
season where tormund says i've seen you
slip a shaft through a rabbit's eye or
fonz I from 400 yards she's kind of a
prodigy with the bow and she had a
fairly close shot at jon snow at the end
of season 3 as much as she feels
betrayed by john and as much fury as she
feels there's also real love there she
has an opportunity here in the courtyard
and she doesn't take it obviously we
have at you a major moment in this
episode with the loss of her grief so we
did the concealed up to it but I knew I
didn't want to get into that particular
scene until as you know it needs to be
fresh they needed a new day and to get
into that because it's going to be
emotional it's gonna be tough Rose
Leslie is such a wonderful actress from
the first time we saw her he was
watching a Downton Abbey episode and
watching this actress and thinking she'd
be really good ignorant and then to see
that final shot which we told neil
marshall one of our one of her favorite
shots of the series that and we very
very rarely do slow motion we don't like
slow motion tends to feel self-conscious
to us and a little bit cheesy but this
one shot we love so much there was no
way when we saw in the director's cut
the nila put in slow loved it the shot
of john cradling a grit in his arms is
is my favorite shot of the episode it
just completely brings you into John's
consciousness and your you experiencing
this moment as he's experiencing it as
something the worst thing that could
possibly happen stretched out over time
longer than you could ever imagine it's
just it's beautiful and heartbreaking
I think I think the idea that Egret has
gone from the world is almost as
difficult for John as the idea that rose
leslie is no longer on the show is
difficult for us
you're not nothing Jon Snow
you